der homosexuelle akt ist natürlich nicht
okay ist klar von dem alten testament
schmusen also jetzt die so eine vorstufe
ja
die großen parteien sind am ende jetzt
gelingt es den radikalen gefährlichen
splitterparteien die wähler in ihre
fänge zu locken und die wollen wir heute
bald vorstellen
ich bin jetzt hier am wahlstand der
partei bibeltreuer christen und ich
stehe jetzt genau neben dem heinz
kaulbach ich bin der landesvorsitzende
pbc jetzt habe ich ihre wahlprogramme
gelesen und es ist ja doch sehr lang
ja wir haben uns überlegt machen wir nur
ganz kurze punkte wären besser gewesen
weil es man braucht lange zum lesen dann
letztendlich was mich auch interessiert
was ich auf der homepage gelesen habe
ist ja der austritt aus der
homosexualität wie genau funktioniert
das meistens oder am besten durch
therapien gut hat die homosexuellen lieb
aber nicht die homosexualität das ist
auch meine meinung
das liegt auch daran weil ich selber
betroffener bin ich finde es auch nicht
okay was kann ich machen sage ich mal
es ist schwierig man kann beten beten
ist eine sache wie ich auch vorher schon
sagt in der therapie war das ist nicht
so ganz einfach aber natürlich die so
unreine gedanken hat man natürlich ist
normal es ganz normal dass wie bei jeder
anderen sagen dass mit einer sucht
vergleich ist dass sich guten vergleich
das ist ungefähr gleich so man muss
daran arbeiten und wir können hilfe
geben das machen wir gerne hilfe gebe
ich dir gerade bei der büso und neben
mir steht katarzyna kruczkowski in kurz
kascha sie wollen die d-mark zurück ihr
motto ist also nrw raus aus der
euro-zone ja nicht nur der weg ganz
deutschland sollte wieder souverän
werden was wirtschaftsfragen angeht also
ganz deutschland ein zitat aus der
euro-zone genau was sagen sie denn
hardlinern die sagen wir wollen nicht
zurück zur d-mark sondern zu reichsmark
also das finde ich verrückt also weil
ich allein in nrw bis 50 milliarden euro
und dass wir genau sie brauchen fordert
50 milliarden euro wollen aber die d
mark zurück wäre es dann nicht
sinnvoller zu sagen wir brauchen 100
milliarden mal sicherlich sicherlich der
homosexuelle akt ist natürlich nicht
okay ist klar
schon im alten testament schmusen also
jetzt die so eine vorstufe wie auch
schon als nicht normal ansehen wenn es
ohne zunge ist kommt so an ich denke in
den er in den arabischen ländern
sieben anbieter wollte ich vielleicht zu
einer normalen vor was ist ihnen noch
wichtig für die wahl für die wahl ist
wichtig dass möglichst keine extremen
kräfte in den landtag kommen
das war doch schon sehr viel
versprechende parteien es gibt aber auch
kleine parteien die überhaupt gar keine
chance haben über die fünf prozent zu
kommen wie diese partei fdp
traumtänzer und damit zurück ins studio
man bin ich lustig oder echt
schlagfertig